it is circling the drain it is not
looking good
and as we get closer and closer to what
would be the start of the college
football season
it really is starting to feel like
it's just a matter of time before the
power five
pull the plug on a fall season maybe
they play in the spring
but it feels like they're getting closer
and closer to conceding
it's impossible to make this work at the
college level
it certainly does mike i laid out i
oh it was a good drink though i need it
uh either way i mean
this is something you and i have been
talking about for the past you know a
few weeks
i and and even before this i don't think
even before we started our break
you know before training camp mid-june
you and i were sitting here going man i
don't know how college football is gonna
pull this off i don't really get it and
you know as we know it's young kids
there's more guys on a football team
certainly there's the school aspect and
how is that going to be handled so
as it looks right now and you know again
this is kind of hashtag
as expected yeah i didn't think college
football was going to be able to figure
all of this out and get on the same page
and come up with a plan i mean we were
complaining about the nfl and lack of
plan
and transparency as far as that
discussion and what that plan is and
we've heard almost nothing from college
football let alone mike i mean i always
like lean on something you say never
heard it i haven't heard i thought it
was
academics first i haven't heard about
college yet school
isn't that why they're there and that
they're always arguing so
you know when i look at those two things
yes i think it's uh highly unlikely that
we have a college football season at
least during this regular fall time
maybe late in fall
early winter it starts up but i i don't
see it happening
when the pandemic really got going and
the colleges shut down and shifted over
to online learning
and the questions first emerged chris
about college football one of the things
i said is you can't have college
football without college
how can you tell 98
no or in some cases 99.9 of the student
body
you stay home but the football players
come
it's not safe for 99.99
of the students but we need the football
players here because we got to play the
games we got to make the money
and and and all along
the threat to the system has been if you
try too hard to pull this
off you're going to expose once and for
all what everybody already knows
right it's a cash generating machine
that's what it is the mid-american
conference pulled the plug on saturday
and you know reportedly the presidents
of the various universities the ball
states kent states
eastern michigan western michigan
central michigan's of the world they
came to the conclusion
the finances don't make sense which
shows you at the core
they're no different than the other
conferences the other conferences the
finances do make sense
they do make sense that's why we
continue to push this it's not about
what's right or what's wrong or what's
safe or what's not
it's about it's a lot of money out there
and the tv
money right with the i would think with
the big conferences compared to the mac
where yes it has a tv
contract but not on the same capacity
the sec
or the big ten have so i i'm just
flushing this out mike
so i'm guessing that would be the reason
it's still economically you know in
their
their their eyes of why they want to do
this
yeah and for the mac for them the big
ticket is
being cannon fodder essentially
pre-season games
for the major conference teams even
though from time to time the mac team
will rise up and bite one of those major
conference teams in the butt
they lose those paydays the tv doesn't
matter
for the mac like it does for the sec acc
the big 10
big 12 and pac-12 and that's why we
see and have continued to see this
effort to continue to reach for that
brass ring that is just
out of reach because i just feel like
you know the nfl has one mission
the nfl's mission is to stage
football games in the fall in pursuit of
an eventual
championship and then lather rinse
repeat do it again again again that's
what they do
colleges are there doing a bunch of
different things you got a bunch of
different
hats that you're trying to wear and and
i just feel like when it comes to
football there's never been
any real leadership that would bring
these conferences together
these schools together and the ncaa has
essentially vacated any and all
responsibility for this although they
did step up last week
with some things that are good for the
players you haven't seen that
push to get that you know some of these
schools chris they don't even test the
players
unless they are symptomatic or have been
proven to be in close contact with
someone who has covet 19.
there isn't a regular testing program
like what we see with the nfl
teams every day every day at least for
the first couple of weeks and then if
everything's good it shifts to every
other day
so i i i just i feel like the absence of
anyone early on saying if we want to
have any chance at doing this this is
what we need
to do nationally or at least among the
five
big conferences this is how we're going
to pull it off
i just feel like you know the coaches
kept going forward full speed ahead damn
the torpedoes
it's just the flu kind of that attitude
you know and i'm not going to name names
but you know
i think the coaches have believed all
along we'll just be able to kind of will
our way through this
and then between the athletic directors
and the presidents i just feel like no
one
at the school level stood up and said
holy crap we got to do
something that makes more sense and no
one at a
more broad level all the way up to the
ncaa
said hey if we want to pull this off
these are the things we got to do and
it's too late to do it now
yeah it is it's way too late to do it
now
i mean how can you feel comfortable if
you're a parent in certain scenarios and
you know you do have a son who's playing
college football that has asthma or
you know has a high body mass index what
we've talked about those type of things
and you don't hear
something concrete or something detailed
to make you feel good about sending your
kid there i understand that and then
you know the ncaa late leadership you
know i mean
i've had issues with that for years i
mean you've heard me complain from time
to time
about that and you know yes it does seem
like at this point with those five power
conferences
um you know they're trying to figure out
their own way first before
even talking to the other people and
trying to figure out a plan to
oh can we get a final four can we have a
champion whatever that may be
you know the sec only seems worried
about the sec right now the big ten's
worried about the big ten
yeah where is the ncaa in all of this to
where they kind of pull it all together
and they're like
okay here's the plan guys all right
you're the big money makers in college
football
you're the ones that everybody tunes
tunes in to watch on a weekly basis
right let's figure this out to formulate
some sort of plan and get a season going
and whatever that
may be and uh it doesn't even seem like
that's close to happening and
you know you can will all you want you
know and i understand there's players
out there that are going we want to play
we want to play and i i understand that
but that doesn't mean that's the best
thing for society right now either
and unfortunately what i'm starting to
like realize with some of these
incidents too is like
you know it seems like something's bad
is gonna have to happen
before some people start to realize like
oh
wait this is this is dangerous or whoa
i can't believe it actually hit home
here and one of our coaches is
you know now on his death bed and you
know we all just said we were gonna play
and push
forward and gosh now we're gonna have to
see our coach and his family
and all those other people who are sad
and you know they're they're
mourning a man that's very sick and it
just feels like that's the way it's
gonna have to hit home in some of these
scenarios and uh i don't think that's
the way it should be either
but you know here's the thing with 160
000
dead since march you'd think that
most people would know somebody by now
to the point where it
will hit home whether it's a loved one a
friend an acquaintance or somebody it
exploded for me
from this and it and it wakes you up
right right right
it wakes you up and you say holy crap we
do need to take this seriously
but chris you mentioned the push by the
players
and it is coordinated it it's as
coordinated as that coordinated as that
effort by nfl players a few weeks ago to
put pressure on the league to get
everything worked out so they could get
to camp
justin fields the ohio state quarterback
trevor lawrence the clemson quarterback
other top prospects
tweeting out last night a graphic
a a pre-made by someone graphic that has
the logos of the five
top conferences with the messages we are
united we want to play here's what it
says
we all want to play football this season
and then under that see
the headline is hey they want to play
hey let them play if they want to play
why are we giving them a hard time
about playing they make demands chris
establish universal mandated health and
safety procedures and protocols to
protect college athletes against covet
19 among all conferences throughout
the ncaa give players the opportunity to
opt out and respect their decision
guarantee eligibility whether a player
chooses to play the season or not
use our voices to establish open
communication and trust between players
and officials
ultimately create a college football
players association with a
representative of the players of all
power five conferences so you know
you're gonna have some
that see this as they're fine they want
to play
i think if you look at it more deeply
they're making
specific demands yeah in order to play
and i don't know that the schools are
going to be all that thrilled
about giving in to these demands because
the first one
having some sort of universal mandated
health and safety procedure
they don't there's none how are they
going to pull it all together how are
they going to have a universal
health and safety protocol that applies
to every school that they just kind of
pull out of thin air
today and get everything on track for
september it's not going to happen
no there's no way it's going to happen
maybe it can happen with each individual
conference maybe the sec can come up
with some certain game plan to where
okay these are the guidelines and you
know the bylaws of which each team has
to follow here and there
you know but yeah it just seems like
it's way too late in the game for that
certainly you know and then yes without
the daily testing and things like that
and then i don't know what are the
protocols what are they doing right now
you know when these kids are leaving
football and doing that
you know i mean you're hearing certain
colleges canceling certain things and
workouts
i mean i just can't imagine how anything
can go smoothly
or work out with the current state i
mean it's just way too late
they're they're too late into the game
so i mean for for the very least there's
just there's no way it's happening in
september it's just the way i look at it
it's just like
are they gonna have football maybe by
november are they just gonna chalk it up
to 2021
and start you know early spring winter
time whatever that may be i just i can't
imagine we're gonna see it this year
and you know that that raises the
question then do you have two full
college football seasons in one calendar
year and are there health and safety
issues there if
you play from january or february until
may yeah
right and then turn around and fire up
the engine again in september and jam
in two seasons in one year there's
a lot of questions just like it was with
the nfl
every time you answer a question or try
to
five more questions pop up in its wake
here's a question for you because this
is a
this is a theory that has been floated
by those in the media who are very
insistent on college football going
forward those who have a vested
financial interest
unlike the players who don't get paid in
seeing these games happen
are are making this argument chris and
we need to flesh this out and see if it
holds any water right
if they don't play college football
right college football gives these guys
structure gives them a reason to try to
stay clean
from the virus it gives them a place
where they can be tested and they can be
monitored and they can be protected
and if we don't have college football
they're just going to go out and do a
bunch of stupid
you know 18 19 20 year old things and
they'll be more at risk
if we don't have college football how do
you feel about that or
well i i don't i don't buy that you know
i mean so
so you know i understand there's a
little bit more of a
yeah i'm with my team and got somebody
yelling at
or you know keeping me in check a little
bit about what we should do
but they're still 18 or 19 years old and
they're gonna be careless at some point
and do something like that so you know i
i don't know if i can like sit there and
buy into that argument all the way there
yeah i i don't know
i don't know about that yeah maybe a
full sequester
school by school is the only one well
yeah that would be it right because
you're right
but but are they going to want to do
that all right and will they respect
that i mean what are you going to have
to do
lock them down in a hotel and monitor
every exit so there's no way they can
get out and no way anyone can get in
it's just see the thing is expensive yes
right
and and it and it and it makes it even
more hypocritical
that these guys who are cogs in a
billion dollar machine
aren't actually getting compensated for
their time they're just getting the
education that in a lot of cases the
coaches don't want them to take full
advantage
of because it gets in the way of the
reason why they're there which is to
basically major in football now you know
and and i
i i i hear that argument about well you
know if they're not playing football
they're going to go out and they're
going to engage in unsafe activities and
they may get
covered 19 anyway the question is do
these schools want to institutionalize
what becomes a potential super spreader
event
yeah that's exactly what aren't testing
the way the nfl is
if you're putting these guys out there
on the practice field we saw the big 10
pull the plug on padded practices until
they can figure out what the hell
they're going to do because they
understand
if you have guys out there that haven't
been tested every single day and one guy
is positive
you can spread it around all of them and
and i think there's a sensitivity to the
community
that it's one thing for individuals to
make bad choices
on their own time it's another thing for
the schools to provide the platform
yeah to do that or spreading the virus
among the players among the coaches to
their families to the community
and even though there's no way to draw
it all back
to where it started from i think that
these university presidents are smart
enough to know
that they're setting up a bunch of petri
dishes that can
ultimately increase dramatically the
infection rates in the community
so that's the difference you don't want
to be responsible for organizing what
becomes a covet 19
party where the virus gets spread
by you by your organization setting up
these football practices and games
without the proper protocols yeah i
think that's the big thing i think
you're right and when
you know i think about my college days
okay and and i know things are different
right now but they're not like
so different i mean we're seeing there's
a lot of cities and places open
and some that are still trying to you
know be in denial
of the situation we're in all together
but i mean i think the big thing is what
you said the super spreader
uh possibility that would be what would
i would scare me
if i'm running in or you know running a
school or in charge of these kids or
whatever it may be where
okay yes we've had practice we're not
testing on a daily basis
man hey hey you know trevor lawrence
here he is he's got a few guys
hey let's go to you know let's get a
burger down the street whatever it may
be
all right let's do that burger fries
come on we're a little hungry
i'm sick of eating the cafeteria stuff
it's real bland because school's not in
we're the only people in school there
so i'm sick of that meal whatever okay
so now you go there
six seven ten guys whatever you're only
testing
once every few days as you mentioned
somebody might have the virus
among that group for those few days now
a bunch of guys on the team might have
it maybe a few of them are at that
restaurant
where does it go from there and that's
where you know
i do think you know we owe it to society
to
not take those chances and be that super
spreader because we've heard enough
horror stories as is
already where there's been those type of
events and it catches like wildfire and
then people end up dying or being in the
hospital really sick for a long long
time and i certainly wouldn't want that
on my conscience i know that
you